I don't know about you. But I think that online shopping is pretty great. Once
Grant realized how much easier many people find it to be, he decided that he
should make his glasses wipers, nozzles and cleaning solutions available for
purchase on the internet. To encourage his customers to buy more merchandise
online, he's come up with a fancy piece for his function that allows them to
save money on shipping cost orr postage, if they spend more money buying his
products. Please note that costs of order here does not include the postage.
And also note that the quantities in each of these columns are measured in
dollars. So, we can read this as, if the cost of the order is less than $10,
the postage is only $2.75. If the order costs between $10 and $50, postage is
$5.00. And for a person who spends at least $50 on the site, they need not have
to pay any postage at all. How much would the total cost, which is equal to the
cost of the order plus the postage, be for each of the following. A, one nozzle
set for $9.99. B, a box of six nozzle sets for $49.99. C, some cleaning
solution for $1.99 and one nozzle set for $9.99. And d, a box of six nozzle
sets for $49.99 and some cleaning solution for $1.99. I've included the dollar
signs for you on all these amounts, so please just write in the numbers.